The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild  is the first Zelda game with full voice  acting  except for Linc who remained silent  what's up with that I'm Tony and this  GameSpot news update comes straight from  Hyrule breath of the wild producer Eiji  Aonuma  explained why the new game includes  voice acting saying that it's hard to  leave an impression on players with just  text but when it comes to link he needs  to stay mute so that players can project  themselves onto him if he says something  the player disagrees with then that  projection is ruined and that's why  you'll be hearing plenty of other  characters speak but link won't be  saying anything The Legend of Zelda  breath of the wild is coming to the Wii  U and NX in 2017 some of the GameSpot  staff got to play the game at e3 so  visit us for even more information and  for all the Nintendo news you need you  already in the right place